Okay.
I
seriously hate that I have to do this story
today.
Um, but I have information about what
is happening on Youtube, which is an extraordinarily
important agenda setting platform at this
point in the world of news and politics.
It just is whether we want it to be or not.
It is.
And what I have to tell you today is terrible.
And if I didn't tell you I wouldn't be doing
my job, um, I am actually worried that I'm
going to get in what we might call trouble
in some way for me even doing this story today.
But what is taking place has to be made as
widely known as possible so that we can at
least try to take control back of what's going
on.
What is taking place is that, uh, Google has
unofficially but sort of officially made youtube
corporate media at this point in time when
it comes to news and politics.
Okay.
Youtube used to be about independent content
of all kinds alternatives to corporate media
that applied a lot to news and politics.
But now as I have been suspect suspecting
for months, and I've been telling you for
weeks, they have rewired their algorithm and
are almost completely stopping recommendations
of independent news and politics channels
like this one like Sam Cedar's, majority of
report, Kyle Kalinsky secular talk and are
instead recommending people watch stead CNNs
youtube channel, Fox News as Youtube Channel,
MSNBC, CS and other legacy corporate media
channels.
Now I don't want to Redo the whole story because
there's so much new data that I have for you
today.
And again, I could get destroyed by youtube
for doing this.
Uh, but I have to tell you because what's
going on in what we've uncovered is, is absolutely
stunning.
Just to refresh a little bit, our channel
has been getting fewer and fewer views from
youtube recommended video algorithm.
When you watch videos on youtube, youtube
suggests other things, watch alongside or
below the video.
The idea is to keep you watching as long as
possible.
Okay?
Uh, we used to get a lot of recommended video
views from Youtube Algorithm.
I told you previously, I estimated that we
had lost about 2 million views per month from
this algorithm recommending our videos more
and more infrequently.
That was a massive underestimate.
There's a disturbing new metric I looked at
on youtube.
Some of the people watching our videos like
anybody else's, some of the people that are
subscribers and some aren't.
Okay?
Of course, you don't have to be a subscriber
to a youtube channel to watch the videos on
that channel.
We have lost millions of non-subscriber views
per month over the last several months and
non-subscriber views are determined by Youtube
Algorithm.
Okay.
This graphic we're putting up on the screen
is disgusting.
The numbers of views from subscribers has
slowly trickled up, which makes sense.
As we gain subscribers over time, we get a
few more views from subscribers over time.
That's the Blue Line on the bottom.
It's a slow uptick.
The red line is non-subscriber views.
This is determined wholly, totally by the
Youtube Algorithm.
A 8 million non-subscriber views in December,
just a straight line decline down to under
5 million in June.
A shortfall, not have 2 million views a month
as I thought, but of 3 million views per month.
Most channels don't even get 3 million views
ever.
Even most active youtube channels don't get
3 million views per year, nevermind per month,
and our shortfall from the decline of only
non-subscriber views is more than 3 million
views per month to a lot of money for us.
I'm not gonna lie now, lots of people wrote
in and said, David, okay, you're losing views
from the algorithm, but who is gaining them?
If you really are right about this, the youtube
audience continues to grow.
If you are losing views from the recommended
video algorithm, someone must be gaining those
views and that is exactly right and I spent
the weekend researching this and I am now
ready to tell you exactly who is gaining and
it's all corporate channels.
You are likely going to be disgusted by this,
but maybe not surprised.
A guy named Mark Ledwidge put together a tool
from publicly available recommendation data
where you can look at the percentages of recommendations
within news and politics to different channels.
Let's put this first image up on the screen.
What you will notice, and I'll describe it
to people who aren't watching is that on May
1st something very specific happened, the
David Pakman show, Kyle Kalinsky, Sam seed.
Now I'm even including Steven Crowder here
because I want to show you that this does
not appear to be politically biased.
All of the recommended views as a percentage
of those days, news and politics recommendations
dropped off a cliff while at the exact same
time the recommended views for CNN, youtube
channel and MSNBC and Fox News's increased.
If you look before May 1st channels like mine
and others, we're getting somewhere in the
range of one to 3% of the recommended views
and news and politics from this broader list
of some of the largest news and politics channels.
On May 1st those numbers crashed and they
went from between one and 3% to between 0.03%
and half a percent.
Now you might think, well, those are all small
numbers, one to 3% down a 0.03 to a 0.5% that's
not a big difference.
Understand that this is a pool of, it's either
hundreds of millions or billions of total
views.
If I am getting 0.1% of the recommendations
and before I was getting 1.5% that is a decline
of greater than 90% okay.
On the same day, early May of this year, CNN,
MSNBC, and Fox went from getting, in the case
of Fox News as youtube channel five to 8%
of the recommended views all the way to 12
to 18% that's a 50% increase of recommended
views for Fox's youtube channel.
CNN, MSNBC, same thing.
Now they may come after me for going public
with this and if that happens, I'm going to
let you know.
But this is serious because it could literally
decimate channels like mine and others that
you might like.
Whether you like channels on the left or right,
I don't care.
It doesn't matter.
This appears to be affecting channels of all
political persuasions.
Let me show you another image.
Just comparing the David Pakman show and CNN,
so it's easier to read the data.
It's not as scrunched as you can see.
The same day, may one 2019 and it remains
the case since then, CNN spikes and we drop.
Let's look at another example.
Compare the David Pakman show youtube channel
to MSNBC.
Again, this is not left, right.
Maybe some of that exists, but this is pro
corporate and anti independent.
Okay, so I hope it's clear now the direction
this is going.
I had many phone calls over the weekend with
all sorts of hosts.
We don't think we can do a damn thing about
this.
As far as youtube algorithm, we're, we're
all exploring options.
We're all worried.
But ultimately if youtube is going to do this,
I don't know what we can do that's completely
within their right to do this.
I just think it is a perversion of their original,
uh, sort of, um, existence, which was independent
content.
Now, just the same old legacy corporate content
that people get through cable subscriptions.
This is the decision that is anti independent
pro corporate views go from independent channels
to Fox News, which is right-wing editorially.
They go from independent channels to MSNBC,
which is center left editorially, but they're
both huge corporate news.
That is the point.
Now in the meantime, there's a ton of crazy
stuff on youtube that's going totally unpoliced
and it's stunning example.
There are youtube ads running for video games,
which clearly violate the copyright of, for
example, Nintendo A. Look at this.
This is an ad for a game called Super Mario
maker too.
This is clearly not an intended game.
This is clearly a total violation of Nintendo's
copyright on Mario, and yet it's on youtube
making money and paying for ads.
Another example, last week I told you that
Gavin McInnes the right wing, proud boys founder,
his content was briefly banned from youtube.
Then allowed back on the vast majority of
the content is not what would be called brand
safe.
He is advertising on Youtube even though the
content itself is not considered brand safe.
What is happening here?
So this is very quickly employed, imploding
weekly.
This is getting worse.
So the only solution is to separate revenue
from advertising.
Okay?
If we separate the revenue that shows like
hours get from the whims of YouTube's algorithmic
decisions, we make ourselves immune to this
toxic and disgusting failed system that has
been identified as toxic and failing for a
very long time.
Uh, and it sort of comes and goes in waves
and what I'm talking about is you've just
got to support the shows you'd like directly.
We make it really easy, okay?
If you go to join pacman.com you can sign
up in under a minute.
It's not a lot of money if you buy one of
those lattes a month.
And I hate these latte comparisons, but they
are sometimes illuminating.
If you buy one latte per month, you can give
us three or four bucks a month.
Um, and it'll actually make a really big difference.
We estimate only 1% of our entire audience
supports us financially.
If we can get it to 2% or 3%, or imagine we
could get it to 5%, uh, the youtube issue
is no longer a problem.
We just focus on doing stories that we want
to do that are the valuable stories that the
audience wants us to do.
Okay?
So we can take ownership of what's going on.
We can't control youtube algorithm, but if
we understand membership culture, if we say,
let's just support the programs we like, we
might spend 100 bucks a month on a cable subscription,
mostly for channels we don't even actually
watch or want to support.
I'll send David Pacman six bucks or I'll go
on patriot and send them a dollar a month.
We do have a coupon code on our website.
It's this is 2020.
It'll give you a 40% discount.
I want you involved at any level because even
a dollar a month is really valuable when you
have 700,000 subscribers on youtube and several
hundred thousand podcasts, listeners, et Cetera,
et cetera.
Even just people throwing in a dollar or two
a month makes a big difference.
June was our second best month ever for new
members.
I would like to make July the best ever, and
if we do that, I will tell you that that's
something that we've done.
I seriously hate that this is happening.
I want to be talking to other hosts, not about
are we going to lose 90% or 80% of our youtube
revenue.
I want to be talking to them about what's
the best content we can make.
How are you covering the upcoming election?
Are we going to the conventions?
Are we doing live broadcasts of debates?
I hate that this has become the topic.
Uh, and if they come after me for talking
publicly about it and sharing this data with
you, I'm going to let you know, believe me.
But in the immediate, whether it's this show
or other shows, if you have a few extra bucks
a month, this is a really good time to say,
I am not going to allow this to destroy programs.
Find Valuable.
Join pacman.com get a membership.
Um, and I'll update you later this week as
to what's going on and how things are going.
Really, really sad.
State of affairs,